let us wait
together
the Braxton family is mourning the death
of their sister Tracy the singer was 50
years old
[Music]
Tracy died on Saturday the late
performer's husband Kevin serrat shared
the news with E.T writing in a statement
quote after a year of privately
undergoing a series of treatment for
esophageal cancer our beloved Tracy
Braxton has gone on to Glory
Tracy's rev tells E.T that she was
surrounded by her family and friends and
among those closest loved ones her four
sisters Tony Tamar Tawanda and Trina who
all shared their grief on social media
I'm blessed that I have my sisters
around me even though they're nosy as
heck but I'm glad that that they are you
know it shows that they're real concern
about me in in my health and my
well-being the Unbreak My Heart singer
posted this tribute along with a
stunning black and white photo with all
her sisters Tony writes in the caption
she was a bright light a wonderful
daughter an amazing sister a loving
mother wife grandmother and a respected
performer Tracy passed this morning as
the snow was falling our Angel is now a
snowflake the Grammy winner ends her
post with a simple but powerful thought
we are family forever Trina shared
Tony's post while Tawanda wrote this
sweet message to her late sister quote
our morning ritual laughing saying good
morning or even watching the same movie
on the phone in silence no one will ever
know just how we were as sisters as for
Tamar she shared an audio clip of money
long song I wish I had a time machine
writing in the caption my dear Tracy
come back my sisters are amazing and I
love them so much and the great thing
about family is that you can have
disagreements but at the end of the day
you always come back to the core and
that's family the Braxtons also received
love from some famous faces like Viola
Davis who praised Tracy on Twitter
calling her a light she also sent her
condolences to the family Hallie Bailey
shared similar sentiments writing oh no
rest in peace Tracy Braxton
Tracy made her Mark in the music world
getting her start at an early age by
singing with her sisters in the church
choir she went on to release two albums
one including her hit single last call
which peaked at number 16 on the
Billboard Hot 100. I'm tired
[Music]
it only grew stronger as a member of the
family's WE tv reality show Braxton
Family Values
[Music]
on the bus
girl I wore this outfit especially for
this trip
so who is the craziest
Tracy
that's not crazy
about our business right selling our
business the network which aired seven
seasons of the series from 2011 to 2020
paid tribute to Tracy in a statement
writing quote Tracy Braxton has been in
the lives of TV viewers for years and
will always be part of the WE TV family
gone far too soon we celebrate her life
and memory and send our heartfelt
condolences to the entire Braxton family
during this difficult time her light and
spirit live on through ups and downs one
thing always remained the same Tracy's
strong bond with her sisters it's a
sentiment that she echoed to E.T in
2019. don't get it twisted they're my
sisters if somebody walk go with them
and I don't like it and they don't like
and they hurting really bad oh believe
me I'm going to step in I am that
protector sister to make sure they're
okay you know let them know I have your
back we will jump up on if you would
jump there we Braxtons I mean come on
now
[Music]